I want to start with congrats on season
three I've seen all of it uh thank you
for making me laugh thank you
um so I
I am curious
um has Rob bribed you with wrexham AFC
jerseys to become where's my Rec Center
[Music]
Jazzy Rob yeah he's not here but if he
was I'd be yelling at him where is my
Rex and Josie right do you find that
he's in a better mood when they're
winning absolutely I mean as they were
they playing when we were filming I
remember it was definitely a photo shoot
one day where they were playing in real
time and we were really I think they won
so we kind of watched him get he's into
it he's very excited he's a big genuine
genuine obviously supporter of the team
and so yeah it's uh it's it seems like
it's a lot of fun it's nice to see him
light up about something that's so
outside of what he's done so you can
tell that he's really really passionate
about it at Comic-Con Megan mentioned uh
during an interview that she knows how
Mythic West will ultimately end she
knows like the final scene and I'm
curious if she has shared that
information oh that was news to us as
well that they knew so I mean yeah if
you can get it out of yeah we'd love to
know
I will never get that information and I
also don't want to know as a fan I want
to get there yeah I respect that yeah
um so listen obviously I've seen all of
season three but what do you guys want
to tell fans that they are what they're
looking forward to this season I really
think that you're getting to see these
characters that you know and love will
love to hate uh back in the world that
they thrive in with a few little tweaks
right like especially for for instance
for Poppy and I and I think you've seen
them in all these different iterations
of their creative collaboration and now
finally we're working on Poppy's idea
it's Poppy is finally the one steering
the ship and in is kind of the first
mate that's supposed to be supporting
her and it's a whole new Dynamic for
them and it's really interesting to see
where it takes them both in terms of
what they create but also the way that
it affects their relationship and then
also yeah and what's also really cool
about this season is
everyone's kind of in a new job almost
happening Dana and Rachel are no longer
testers Jabba's oh job Brad is no longer
monetization yes it's interesting David
is no longer just the producer yeah and
Poppy and eyes are that's so true wow
it's so smart that they did that one of
the things that I was really impressed
with was um the grimpop Studios
Production design of that of of where
you guys are working it's like a really
great set and I'm just curious what it
was like for both of you seeing it for
the first time
it was like a magical experience kudos
to the set design team because they yeah
slated it was so beautiful that I I
didn't want to touch anything yeah and
it felt very futuristic and like they
weren't on the set of Mythic quests no
it feels like a James Terrell Pace it's
like it is a work of art and the light
in there feels like you can touch it
um and then also there were all these
funny thing protocols that we had to
follow because it was just such a
delicate yourself like we yeah when you
see the show it is just white it's white
everywhere and so we had to wear little
booties over our shoes so as not to
leave Footprints and uh poppy is
constantly snacking and I was very aware
of dropping snacks on the pristine floor
which I want to do some of your
castmates have started directing
episodes and I'm curious for both of you
is it something that you are asking the
higher ups if you will for season four
well I think that the sorry did you did
you want to go I was going to say that
it's a very open space with supporting
us and to our future endeavors and
what's really nice is we we got to watch
all of our castmates direct uh firsthand
and they're so good at it everyone's so
talented yeah to to act in a show that
you're directing and they're coming from
a perspective where they already know
the show in and out which was really
nice and and I have to say as well there
were definitely elements of it that were
also just kind of funny to watch like
without it giving anything away the
episode that David directs he also as
David Hornsby was directing and David
brittles be the character was wearing a
ridiculous costume and so he's he's
acting in these scenes as David
riddlesby and his ridiculous costume and
then yelling cut and directing where the
camera needs to go next or what your
performance should look like still in
the ridiculous costume and that was
definitely one of the highlights of the
series I don't want to do any spoilers
at all but Charlotte I am curious what
was your reaction after watching episode
I believe it's eight
uh that would be the special episode
right yes
I was so blown away and I was lucky
enough that I did get to uh be on set
for some of the time that was being shot
and again without giving anything away
it was special to me for really personal
reasons uh and um I'm really excited to
see how uh the audience reacts and I'm
really excited for Australia to see that
episode yeah that that was a uh I
thought that was a really great episode
and the casting on that was excellent
incredible like speaking of talent the
they're uh yeah there's an actor in that
episode that's really giving me a run
for my money
right I I agree
um what's cool is you guys were picked
up for season three and for season four
at the same time which is great how much
have you actually been told about season
four or is it sort of like you guys are
finding out script by Script we haven't
been yeah we don't know anything about
it really because you know
you know kind of a thing that
they're so gosh they're so naive aren't
they I do feel like at the end of every
season poppy is given something that
she's so excited to explore and then you
pick up the next season and actually it
turns out to be a nightmare yay and uh
that's the way it goes yeah I can't wait
to see what happens in season four for
both of you I'm curious in the three
seasons you've made so far
um which shot or sequence ended up being
the toughest for you whether because you
kept laughing because of a camera move
or just whatever the reason
you know which one I'm gonna say I can't
I know it's one of two what are you
doing okay I was gonna say that it's the
this wasn't super complicated but we
were laughing a lot me talking yeah
is it there was a scene but two things
were supposed to happen I was supposed
to be cool already an impossible feat
and also I had to catch something yeah
even what you had to throw something at
me and I had to catch it but she's
supposed to catch it in the course not
looking at the things she's catching it
was I did a really bad job and you did a
really bad job of keeping a straight
face yeah I did I was trying to be cool
it's hard to be cool when one of your
best friends is standing opposite you
laughing at how Uncle you are it was six
in the morning as well that was
definitely the reason the six in the
morning yeah can I I have to go but how
many takes did it take too many many
yeah too many I think they were starting
to get frustrated with us a little bit
yeah they were like is there another way
that you could handle the keys I was
like I can get it I also that was the
day that I was like I should wink in
this thing yeah and everyone was like
please don't wink
on that note again I just want to thank
you guys for making me laugh and um uh
you know congrats on a great season
thank you so much